eu vou contar um bocadinho as histórias
das minhas histórias do infinito elas na
verdade começaram há uns anos quando
estava a trabalhar no escritório eo meu
filho manoel que na altura tinha 5 anos
interrompeu meu trabalho importante com
uma pergunta que era pai
qual é o maior número de todos e eu não
queria distrair diz o maior número todos
ao infinito
o meu filho manoel sei eu e passado
nunca nem voltou e pareciam cada centavo
mesmo assim o pai o maior número todos
não é infinito
como não é infinito não pai ao infinito
se um filme de 21 fim nesse trecho
nesse momento percebi que eu tenha
compreendido o infinito ao mesmo tempo
sei que o próprio tinha se calhar uma
compreensão um pouco deficitária deste
conceito e vn cidade contar esta
história a minha própria pessoa
então eu prefiro falar do infinito eu
acho que devemos começar pela palavra em
si ea palavra infinito é composta a
partir do étimo ti no finess o fim mês
para os humanos
é o termo do território obviamente que a
palavra filhas aparece a palavra fim a
palavra finesse aparece por exemplo num
carro do noroeste da península ibérica o
cabo finisterra e também suas por
exemplo na palavra finança que é uma
palavra muito engraçada porque junta um
ótimo time como a palavra germânica
ainda que quer dizer contrato finança
quer dizer por ter um contrato através
do pagamento mas agora a uftm chinês
algo fixo embora observa em força que
têm prefixo embu pega em uma palavra com
segurança
agora coloca o ine
optar em insegurança
peguem tranquilidade em tranquilidade e
o infinito é isto a hunter 11 finesse
representar um prefixo i no porto vá
esse termo é por isso que o infinito
surge de uma forma tão íntima associada
aos nossos processos de crescimento
nós sabemos que os investimentos faz
através das muitas vezes de transgressão
do pisar do imi é é curioso que no fundo
infinito lembramos um caminho é
biografia de busan
vivo numa espécie de círculo estreito 1
do mundo é perfeito não há dor até ao
rio até o dia em que eu então percebe
que a ao sofrimento e quando eu percebi
que é o sofrimento quebras
essa unidade e eu vai iniciar a sua
procura uma questão relevante a pensar
mas quando é com infinita com o conceito
de estrutura no pensamento humano
eu penso que as primeiras representações
do infinito ocorrem no período neolítico
quando os seus humanos começam a
acidentar izar assim faz sentido se
começamos a centralizar mos a cultivar
os nossos treinos
começamos a ter a noção dos nosso limite
o limite do mundo conhecido e os
próximos que nós contamos com o infinito
do desse período são essencialmente
espiral espiral as suas muitas vezes
como um símbolo mágico ou um símbolo
protetor mas é claramente um símbolo que
os nossos antepassados associaram a
futuridade por exemplo nos minis
plantados no interno é possível ver lá
em das marcas de espirais que foram
traçadas e por exemplo
neste ano a mulher futuridade reparem
bem onde é que os piratas foram
desenhadas justamente nas antas da minha
é claro que o infinito sujo para os
nossos antepassados naturalmente
associado ao mistério da origem não é
como se a nossa vida se desenvolver se a
partir de 1 1 ponto
aparece a nossa memória mas é claro que
a vida humana a vida humana tem dois
filhos dois filhos inquietantes é o
nosso investimento e é a nossa morte
reparem como é que o povo designou os
mortos
o final aqui os que atingiram o termo da
existência
isto obriga falar um bocadinho dos
infernos
o inferno é um mundo complexo
na antiguidade se na antiguidade as
mitologias e as regiões arranjar uma
explicação coletiva para todos nós
em relação à morte a morte é uma questão
muito mais individualizada e complexa
diga se de passagem
os gregos imaginavam vários rios a
conduzir aos infernos o qual o apronto
tinge o cocito o flyer tom e existe
talvez aquilo que é o mais inquietante
jesus o éter está associado à nossa
palavra o taj há quem beba as águas do
oeste têm através só viu esquece quem
foi é forma mais segura e os mortos não
voltarem para nos assombrar no funeral é
uma história muito curiosa que está na
origem da fundação de uma vila
portuguesa e que inclusivamente foi uma
história teve um enorme impacto na
interminável foi fundada pelos geógrafos
chamado travão na região tinha sido
enviada para pacificar o norte da
península ibérica é confrontos com o rio
ia ser um diálogo entre os soldados
tiveram medo
acharam que se interessassem por outro
lado diz que se ambos ganharam
esqueciam-se da casa da mulher dos
filhos recusaram-se a troçar perante
esta situação dos quais motivos o
general tomou iniciativa atravessa para
o outro lado e começar a dizer o nome
dos soldados um que é como quem diz eu
não esquece é com clima ponto limas
limites é o rio a que os romanos é o
nome que comandavam a letters
é claro que esta história tem de certa
forma um significado é um significado é
o homem que se apropria do medo da morte
que venço medo da morte é pequeno
conhecimento que o infinito e aquela
lista
no fundo a lista dos nomes é preciso ver
que a lista é forma literária mais
antiga para designar o infinito por
exemplo merda em leiria quando quer
mostrar que os soldados gregos que se
encontram diante tróia são muitos e os
mesmos nomes deus são páginas e páginas
nomes sonantes bom há um outro infinito
que eu gostaria contar o infinito
negativo que tenho que se prendem com
contas fundamental da nossa cultura
foi um teste coberto com o século 18 um
diplomata francês chamado antônio galã
que foi aprovado para a frança para
curto para entretê-los novos recordes
mensais e altas que narra inúmeras
histórias que no fundo são histórias
contadas entre o século 19 os séculos
histórias contadas pelos caravanistas
que transitavam todo mundo islâmico
vocês pesquisar bem do que estou a falar
de falar das mil e uma noites
a história das mil e uma noites têm por
base ou por enquadramento uma história
terrível traição
o sultão a um malgache gosta muito de
assumir a nossa minha amiga engano e eu
desci vi de captar a mineira
mas essa vingança não acalma eu tive
todas as noites vai casar todos os dias
e esposa uma mulher para depois de furar
ou matá la novia assim ele é bastante
violentos diga se de passagem a um dia
em que a escolha vai recair sobre serasa
que é filho do vizinho e cheiras água
pesa apenas uma coisa sou tão deixa eu
contar uma história a minha irmã que a
minha mãe tinha dificuldade de não ser à
noite então é irmã o vavá o quarto terá
dado conta a história a uma história
muito envolvente acontece cheirado não
treme na história
o sultão fica em dúvida mas como é
mandatária será usado no seu mandado
matar a serasa anunciou esta história
então eu eu consegue mais um dia a dia e
dia após dia
ao longo de muitas noite mais mil noite
mil nenhuma noite
a um dia do fatah em que cheirava
comparece nesta sala do trono leva três
crianças uma escola que vai gatinhar max
ainda se em função dos filhos theo e do
sul tão obviamente não só negativa
naquelas noites e o que acontece é que
será usado para o sultão implora ele
comece eu sou tão disse
eu já tinha provado há muito tempo e eu
acho que é legítimo nós pensávamos que
eles viveram felizes para sempre
eu gostaria de vos mostrar a imagem do
sultão eu gostaria de mostrar outra obra
de arte que eu acho que contém talvez
uma das apresentações mais tocantes do
infinito
eu penso que vocês todos conhecem este
quadro as selvas meninas de velázquez e
as que estão expostas no museu do prado
aparentemente quem olha para este quadro
ver um retrato escort com a infanta
margarida teresa no centro
de fato quando nós olhamos com carinho
mais atenção percebemos que existem
alguns elementos perturbadores no quadro
primeiro elemento perturbador o espanhol
espanhol o fundo e nem os pais vez foi
tirar a imagem basta do casal real do
rifle corte da venda
outro elemento de perturbação
o próprio pinto está presente na cena
está ali com a cruz sempre há quem diga
se de passagem que na altura em que o
pintou o quadro ainda não lhe foi
atribuída e curiosamente surgiu também
uma tela nunca vou letal e pinto o
espectador cristiane as está pintado o
rei a rainha que estão enfrenteu ou está
a pintar a infanta aquela tela que ela
está poderá ser o próprio quadro que nós
estamos a ver estas questões o vai então
se desorientou menos um pouco
a 1001 interpretações das meninas de
velázquez
eu permito juntar apenas uma é minha
temos que compreender nunca na história
deste quadro o que no fundo a história
do relaxo quesito flip quanto vê lá acho
que a gente vai para a corte espanhola
muito novo com 18 anos
no mesmo ano em que flip quarta assumir
o trono com 16 a uma ligação de amizade
que vai criar outros dois em que é muito
profunda são feitos completamente oposta
ao que normalmente é preciso que uma
amizade funciona
fui quarto é um homem sensível bastante
possível
velasquez é um homem formato e tranqüilo
a ligação deus durante durante estes
anos todos
o flip quarto das loucas radicamente
todos os dias para ver o velasquez
pintar em 1646 a um episódio dramático
na vida do flip quarto é morte do
príncipe herdeiro o principal da zahar
carlos um filho muito amado um filho
muito amado e para a morte do filho o
pai toma uma decisão drástica eo manda
desmantelar o quarto princípio como quem
diz estas memórias ou não as quero
e curiosamente o quarto do princípio os
aposentos do príncipe são convertidos
não atue dos pintores reais e é preciso
atacar e eu acho que a sede no caso
o rei vai visitá lo ao longo de muitos
anos não é e neste quadro realmente nos
é destinado a este quadro é o diálogo
entre dois amigos em que a um amigo
procura consolar o outro de uma tristeza
é isso que explica em parte o mistério
daquela neva cinzenta sobre a figura do
raio ea ilumine os orientadores mundo
subterrâneo no quadro de velázquez por
exemplo aquelas duas pinturas lá ao
fundo existem realmente são pinturas que
são inspiradas nas metamorfoses de
ovídio uma é de cada atenas minerva a
outra é de cada pólo para minerva e
poucos são os deuses
me dado conhecimento atenas é deusa das
artes e do conhecimento técnico
apolo o deus do autoconhecimento morar
com delphi
a frase está escrita e notes elton
conheça a si próprio e portanto este
quadro é considerado que desconhece a ti
próprio
sou assim ultrapassar absoluto eu faço
outra coisa que eu acho que é domingo
gância enorme
todas as linhas do quadro convergem num
ponto fuga
nesse ponto de fuga está além daquela
porta aberta onde se vê uma luz é como
se eu acho que a licença flip
vamos sair deste quarto onde as nossas
emoções podem ser tão difícil
é claro que vocês perceberam que eu
tenho um objetivo nesta história é como
quem diz uma agenda
eu sou pessoa de matemática
eu venho falar do infinito vamos falar
de uma matemática que não é bom em
matemática da escola
a matemática da escola matemática e
científica e acadêmica é uma matemática
abstrata e implacável é uma matemática
que terminava uma matemática certa forma
transporta-nos a um lugar um pouco na
vivo ela mudou o mundo
ela parece dirigir o mundo a matemática
dos falo e gerem novas inquietações com
aquelas do meu filho
diga se de passagem que dá em que as
crianças percebem que há uma infinita é
mesmo nada em que elas percebem que os
pais vão morrer não é uma matemática
sensível e que é inspirada pelas nossas
intuições inquietações mais profundas
eu gostaria de mostrar vos aqui
uma pequena vertigem do infinito
[Música]
o
háháhá
[Música]
é óbvio que tinha que chegar ao fim
certo eu gostaria apenas de dizer com o
fim
é um lugar complicado o fim é uma linha
bastante instável o fim
por vezes pode ser doloroso quando
implica uma exploração do empreendimento
no caso desta apresentação é importante
é nós no fundo lembrarmos que o infinito
pode ser assustador mas também pode ser
com sua obra pode ser certa forma a
construção de uma certeza do que pra lá
em do limite que nos confronta existe
tal exige tal que chama por nós e eu
penso que agora sim aumento terminar
esta apresentação
obrigado
[Aplausos]
a provocação só ao fim
o aparelho se é ver o cantor são mateus
problema cima
obrigado
[Aplausos]